what's up guys I made sure to wear my
I'm kind of a big deal shirts for this
intro because we're kind of a big deal
now we got an interview jason blum from
Blum house pictures and Leigh Whannell
who is the director of Invisible Man
upgrade wrote saw co-starred in it wrote
the insidious films who does he play nat
john specks of tucker in specs exactly
it's a great time the best seven minutes
of our live coming your way right now
because Invisible Man is coming out May
26 that's a Tuesday day after the
holiday and what's it going out on John
blu-ray Home Video ultra 4k any physical
media you want except laser discs and
VHS and when think jamming Universal
offered to let us interview them as part
of the press we jumped at the
opportunity because if you guys saw any
of our trailer reactions or our movie
review
we loved the hell out of the film so
thank you think Jam thank you Universal
for giving us this opportunity and of
course because it's happening during the
pandemic we had to do it via zoom which
is actually more comfortable for us and
so yeah every once in a while it's very
rare that you might hear like a little
audio glitch or whatever but it actually
came out pretty good
enjoy here today with Leigh Whannell and
Jason Blum we are so excited to be here
out of the three movies we saw in the
theaters this year Invisible Man was
easily the best one we caught this rice
because all the other competitors fell
over and needless to say needless to say
I was absolutely outraged that the
Academy is gonna bend their rules this
year I think it's an out I think it's
outrageous and unfair yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] that'll be our headline right
here for this interview today
thank you for taking the time to talk to
us during this my first question today
would be the reputation that's often
associated with Blum house is that film
makers are often given creative freedom
to really fulfill their vision so I was
wondering like what's the working
relationship so you got to work together
a couple times now well it's a working
relationship often like between you two
and pre-production or during film is
there anything specific in the Invisible
Man that jason creatively suggested that
really changed the scene or is there
anything you two might have butted heads
about the Jason yell at Leigh we need a
headline I think it's great I mean I
think Blum House has a lot of great
creative input I think that you know
when I look at the script and the movie
we shot I see a lot of their input notes
I need that feedback you know the thing
with feedback is you know and notes and
you need to trust the source you know
you need to have a good working
relationship with the person who you're
talking to and you need to trust their
tastes and overly trust
Balam houses tastes the people Jason and
the people that work for him and it's a
small crew of people you know we're not
talking about Disney here where it's
hundreds of people in a building it's
it's a small company that they do a lot
and they make a lot of stuff but the
actual company I think is the feature
film department is a small cruel people
that I work with in and I just love
collaborating with them it's it's easy
it's it's I think and Jason has this
great ability to just let you make the
film you're gonna want to make and he'll
weigh in if it meet you can pick up the
Batphone I call it picking up the
Batphone and say Jason I hate to pickup
the Batphone but I got this serious
problem and he'll deal with it you know
that's awesome
that's good feel good so you're James
Gordon yeah
we met eleven years ago has leadly
pointed out in the last interview in
2009 we've made seven to seven this is I
think our seventh movie and you know the
great thing about working with some of
these we haven't worked with anyone as
many times as we work with Lee and the
great thing about that is that were
great personal friends and business
partners and so there's a super comfort
he's not worried about hurting my
feelings I'm not worried about hurting
his feelings so we save an enormous
amount of time by not dancing around
we're very direct and Lee knows you know
I have an unwavering belief in him
creatively so to answer your question
about a fight we would never if it gets
to that point I give up because I can
tell you guys right now he'll be right
and I'll be wrong way more than the
other way around so we don't get to that
level because because if Lee feels
strongly about it I can speed 2.0 oh
yeah oh no did we get back yeah you are
you were telling us a story about how
you're belittling Lee on set of the I
love that Jason does that I mean I don't
there was a situation with with the
trailer for the film where there was
this big argument about how much to show
and how much not to show how much Jason
was on my side and he but he's so
pragmatic it's not like he's like
whatever you want it's like he is my god
it's it's not combative it's just honest
it's it's good it's the way it should be
I mean you know as soon as as soon as
that tension starts to rise between two
personalities in the making of a film
you know you're in trouble because
making a film is already hard if you add
personality clashes I mean it's it's
brutal and imagine so well I think I
like one minute left you want to anyone
else I mean just curiosity's sake you
guys are both pretty innovative in terms
approach to movies and stuff like that
and with the pandemic going on and the
sort of out-of-the-box thinking that
that requires with a lot of productions
halted and stuff like that and bloom
house being the studio that's made films
like unfriended and things that are
unorthodox that way is there any way in
which you're inspired to kind of create
during all this or create in a new
fashion because of all this um you know
I'm kind of shying away so many people
are doing that it's it's not honestly
it's not that interesting to me I think
we have very little memory I think in
six months whether it's eight months or
six months or three months twelve months
you know we're gonna be back to normal
and you know I don't think people are
gonna be one reminded of it so much so
you know I've had a bunch of projects
pitched to me like let's see this oh
there's there's one I think I think the
story it's this you know it is like you
know it is somewhat you know unfriended
was was a was a was a pandemic movie
before there was a pandemic shot you
know whenever there's one storyline that
I kind of I'm attracted to but I'm not
I'm focused on getting back to regular
production work we have a movie that I
think we're gonna get up and going in
six weeks and and I'm I'm really more
focused on that I think it's dangerous
to rush in and be like I'm gonna write
the quarantine script the follies of
those Lambada movies they just rush too
quick they should have waited with the
Lambada dancing they say that the
Lambada was the superior movie to the
forbidden dance um you know you just
can't rush into this stuff you gotta you
gotta wait 10 years to make your
Lombardo movie I will think thank you
both for your time and please be safe
and thank you for the seriously the
movie is absolutely incredible
gonna be my favorite movie of the year
probably thank you thank you guys again
for watching that make sure to subscribe
to the real rejects click the
notification bell please hit that like
button if you did enjoy this video once
again Invisible Man comes out May 20
sixth rent it buy it do whatever the
hell you wanna do with it but show some
support cuz it's actually a really
bitchin we're definitely buying our own
copy
oh yeah that's for sure because I
accidentally said in the email we don't
need a copy that we could have gotten
for free so now I'm gonna spend my own
money to go buy it is intentional we
were like you know what no universal we
were going to paint we will write yeah
keep your charity copy hey let's do up
you know who's not invisible oh I see
all the time and my heart all I do is
look in here because she may not live in
California
Adelia chamber Linda someone who means
the absolute world to me I know right
now the quarantine situation the
pandemic situation is not the easiest in
your hometown not the easiest being
cooped up in your home having a
difference of opinion with your family
on so many important things in the world
but besides all those struggles you've
been having your positivity has been
going a long way and making this
individuals life be that much more
meaningful I love talking with you every
single week I love the exchanges that we
have back and forth you even sent me
over a possible quiz to take to help me
study for the inner geekdom you're the
only patron who's done that you've gone
the extra month Thank You Adelia for
looking out for us every single possible
way and for being constantly supportive
and vulnerable with us you're one of the
best people in the world I've ever
gotten to know I love them out of you
thanks for watching me in the middle of
the night I know you're there I know it
I know it's you and I'm very flattered
it's good to see the invincible job I
get is as well because she's invisible
she's got like they're easy I don't want
to spoil you funny movies too funny stop
being funny stuff so funny it's so funny
you have to be shot